buongiorno studenti oggi dottore essere
nano come mette pisa dottore aver visto
lampada che i gesti maxi l'ump essersene
innamorato quindi oggi storia può vale a
replicare la val amp con esca rimedio
come detto in precedenza oggi totò
ricreare lampada la valanga come che
maxi lama da un pack essa ci lava
all'interno non esserci lava esserci
cose molto semplici noi vedere oggi
abbiamo olio abbiamo colorante rosso
perché lava lampa verde colore rosso
perchè è il re nello in più avere
cucchiaino per mescolare ma al coperto
non sapere che cosa essere per non dover
inserire dentro detto ingredienti e poi
ingrediente fondamentale noi fa e oggi
esperimento provare a fare la valanga e
dentro bottiglietta di succo che dottor
aver bevuto un'ora prima
oggi totò per svitare e poi come poter
fare al caso col tacco non ne sarei
chiudono più salienti non rispondono
però non essere rischioso se essere
rischioso colpani satelliti versare un
pochettino di acqua all'interno circa un
quarto di acqua all'interno totò gaber
occhio misura tivo quindi sapere
esattamente quando essere 44 essere
esattamente inserire due gocce tine di
colorante rosso all'interno di
bottigliette alla volante questa essere
molto più
fare niente dove mischiare
[Musica]
per inserire un pochettino di olio totò
riina dottore aprire olio può inserire
questa essere solo per bere gli
scienziati stato re maya pertolio come
funziona
guidava imbuto e inserire olio
all'interno di lava l'ump appena creata
che deve essere funzionante sono totò
ricambiare marca di fuoco sembrare già
la valanga quasi funzionante perché
vedere volle vedere cose strane densità
di olio essere maggiore di quella di
acqua questo non avere le pensa mente
fatto sapere inserire al caffè al petto
che non avevano capito cosa essere a
casa perché lava rampe essere
influenzata e necessitare pastiglia
inserire all'interno al capezzolo e
chiudere cellulare dottore girare la
essere effetto incredibile cucinare lava
l'ump e funzionale davvero non essere
solo in fantasie di totò esserci neve
molle che sembrava proprio quelle dietro
molto pivot però ecco questo essere
scenario per chi volesse farlo in
youtuber con pochi soldi fare questo
possono fare come dottore appare in
salita e abbia creato lama lampo e
funzionante totò che essere molto fiero
di se stesso
ricordare pastiglie per me senti e per
mettere all'interno di acqua cosa molto
importante da ricordare prendere
esperimento molto più funzionale
necessitare di tecnologia moderna di
mela nella per due ore per nome la vera
mela l'altra dottore adesso attivare
torcia
perché nella di ben 9 e necessità né per
far funzionare bene spririto guardare
con 200 gli inservienti per cortesia
spegnere luci al di là di totò per 3 2 1
vs
l'esperimento vedersi molto meglio con
luce di torce di mela che puntare su
lava lampe direttamente dal basso e
effetto essere molto molto molto carino
per non aver speso neanche un sogno
quindi totò è molto bravo in effetti
speciali
totoro essere diventato molto importante
come vedere qua essere anche su
copertina di magazine shops in banzi
dottore aver esperimenti dedicati a
magazine voi poter trovare all'interno
scannerizzando con quarto e poter
trovare all'interno di magazine anni
queste incredibili creature che il
dottore trovato smi lo conte è trovato
anche foca che a vergiate scatolato vuoi
poter trovare magazine da metà gennaio
in edicola trovare anche con faccia di
dottore e con animaletti bene e spero il
20 incredibile finire qua ragazzi il
dottore tornare molto presto promesso
dottore ringraziare voi non hanno visto
video mettere mi piace ischi non sia
canale e poter cliccare qua sopra perché
vedere playlist di vecchi video
direttore oppure avere video incredibile
qua in basso a sinistra a destra in base
alla vostra concezione vedere video qua
e invece esserci canale tito torre
iscriversi se non essere iscritti attore
vederle poi molto preso
[Musica]